Eric Young asked what moment triggered
your obsession with the topics outlined
in the biblical series and maps well
that's a good question I actually don't
know the answer that I wouldn't say it
was a moment I know that from the time I
was about 16 to the time that I was 24
so I had recurrent nightmares about
nuclear war and so that was certainly
part of it and they were very vivid and
very realistic and so and certainly my
reading especially about the Holocaust
also and then later Solzhenitsyn's
accounts of the Gulag Archipelago for
example and the horrors there that was
also a major contributor it was my
concern about the Cold War I would say
that was really the trigger in general
because I wanted to understand I took a
political science degree first and
looked at it from a political
perspective but most of my professors by
the time I was in my third or fourth
year insisted that the reason that
people fought the reasons that people
thought were economic and I never did
believe that because well people fight
about the things they value but it isn't
obvious like why people value the things
they value you know so it's a
psychological issue as far as I'm
concerned with and not an economic issue
and so it was my discomfort
dissatisfaction with the standard
political science viewpoint or
economically point combined with this
strange obsession I had about the Cold
War maybe that's associated to some
degree with my proclivity to depression
I mean who knows you know I don't know I
was obsessed with it and it isn't
obvious why things grip you and shake
you like a rat you know I guess
something there's something about that
that seems to be associated with what
people used to call destiny so but it
certainly wasn't obsession when I was 23
or 24 when I started writing maps of
meaning I was thinking about it 16 hours
a day at like top speed just non-stop
and the only relief I could get from it
really was to go work out with weights
which I did for quite
long time gained about 35 pounds in
about a year and a half working out with
weights and I had to quit because I was
eating so much was taking up like half
my life so anyways I don't know what it
was you know who knows who knows what
what darkness lurks in the bottom of a
soul knowing why it's there maybe it was
also the fact that I could see in myself
the tendencies that might lead people to
do terrible things and I was also very
very curious about that so maybe that
was an encounter with the union shad it
was something like that jeremyhill chef
says will you lecture in the Netherlands
yes as a matter of fact I'm coming to
the Netherlands in January to lecture
there I'll put the link to that up on my
website at some point in the relatively
near future so